hey guys Greg Knuckles here with string
theory calm back with the ninth
installment of our daily Q&A series and
the question today is a pretty common
one what are the best sources of
information for athletes or coaches to
build their knowledge base let me just
start by saying probably not blogs
probably not YouTube channels that
includes my website and that includes
this YouTube channel
once you've already dug into the
resources I'm going to suggest reading
stuff online watching YouTube videos as
long as you choose that information
judiciously that can be a good way to to
deepen your understanding maybe learn
you know a few more tips a little bit
more nuance that perhaps you weren't
aware of before but the things I'm going
to suggest in this video are I think
going to be better resources for most
people okay so first things first I
think the best thing the best place to
start is going to be with textbooks I
know that's not a particularly popular
solution most people don't like just
sitting down and reading a textbook but
when it comes to really gaining both a
large breadth and depth of knowledge you
really can't do better than a textbook I
think the biggest benefit you get out of
a textbook is just it really helps you
hone your [ __ ] detector i I see a
lot of questions comments feedback on
videos I make articles I write from
people asking about something that
probably wouldn't be a question at all
if they just understood really basic
physiology or really basic anatomy or
really basic biomechanics and it's one
of those things like textbooks they
aren't fun
they aren't fun to read but if you read
them and understand them and it sticks
with you it's going to make everything
else you
from then on out it's going to make that
much much more beneficial because you'll
have a lot easier time identifying good
information and identifying bad
information know what to stick with know
what to avoid and also you'll have more
context for the information that you do
learn so it'll probably stick with you
better and be more beneficial for you so
with that in mind the textbooks that I
would recommend every lift or get is one
just a basic anatomy and physiology
textbook I have the 1 by beta land Earl
I think it's very good X in exercise
physiology textbook I have will more
Kinney and cos well I think it's very
good for more on strength training
specifically the science and practice of
strength training bodies at sea or ski
and Kramer is exceptional and then round
that out with really any good
introductory biomechanics textbook and a
human nutrition or sports nutrition
textbook most of them are going to have
the vast majority of the same
information and I'm not particularly
partial to any of them so that is where
you should start the next thing is going
to be talking to people who have a solid
education background who have also
accomplished the things you want to
accomplish so you know talking to other
athletes and coaches who you know have
worked with athletes you want to work
with or who have accomplished something
in their sport that you want to
accomplish so really a deep
understanding that's going to be the
marriage of both you know just facts
book learning with experience that's
that's where true deep understanding
comes from and so at first you can't you
can't hack experience you can't
meaningfully speed up that timeline you
just have to put in the work and put in
the years and so with textbooks that is
going to give you that knowledge base
and you can acquire that pretty quickly
I mean textbook 600 pages put in 20 or
30 pages a night
you know you can read the textbook in a
month 20 days again it's not going to be
fun to read but you can pick up a lot of
information very quickly that way that's
that's going to be the fastest part of
the education process and then talking
to people who have been at it for a long
time and have accomplished what you want
to accomplish that's not as good as your
own experience but you're also going to
be able to glean lessons from their
experience to you know give you things
to look out for in in your own
experience in your own training in your
own coaching and then after that just
time I've been I've been lifting now for
twelve years and I've been coaching for
seven eight and I mean still to this day
like I I will tend to defer to lifters
who you know may have not lifted as much
as I have but if they've been in the
game for twenty thirty years they'll
probably have insights about the
training process that I don't have and
same thing with coaches coaches who have
been doing doing it for a long time and
have really been making the efforts to
continually improve you know I I think
I'm pretty good for for the amount of
time and experience that I have but you
know I I can't put myself in a time
machine and just speed up twenty thirty
years of experience of learning so
number one teach yourself in textbooks
right away learn those as quickly as you
can and refer back to them constantly
make sure that information stays in mind
next thing talk to people who have that
life experience and then can help kind
of guide you show you the way and then
after that it's it's just a matter of
training coaching for a long long time
with a with a conscious effort for
getting better that's those are the
three in my opinion those are the three
best sources of education for most
people and then you know again once
you've
once you've done the first and second
steps as you're putting in the reps as
you're putting in the time reading blogs
watching YouTube channels that stuff is
good but it's it's not going to be as
meaningful it's not going to give you
the same depth and breadth of
understanding as talking to people who
have walked the walk and as you know
building that knowledge base from
reading textbooks so yeah that's that's
my basic answer to that question and I
know some people like I on some level I
know that that's not particularly
helpful advice because I do know a lot
of people just simply won't read
textbooks I hey I've been recommending
this for a long time and I think maybe a
half dozen people have actually gone out
and picked up the textbooks I've
recommended and actually read them so if
if you really really don't think you're
going to go that route some other good
resources I would recommend my own here
the art and science of lifting by myself
and Oh Mart you saw the muscle and
strength of pyramids by Eric Helms are
also very very good and scientific
principles of strength training and the
Renaissance five by Mike written by Mike
dis Ratelle are also very very good so
if you if you are really really against
reading textbooks those would also be
some good suggestions but I would not
recommend any of those resources my own
included over starting out over starting
out by reading textbooks so again just
to recap read textbooks talk to people
who who have been walking the wall for a
long time to try to learn from their
experiences and then just spend the time
training coaching gaining that
experience which is invaluable but you
can't you can't rush it just takes time
so that is the video if you liked it
please like and subscribe and if you
have questions ask them in the comments
below and if yours is my favorite I will
pick an answer it in that next
video so until then hope your training
is good hope you have a great day and I
will see you in the next video